let's jump to this next story
and uh this one's this one's interesting
it's very interesting yeah
from politico
trump white house exerted pressure on
fda for covid19 emergency use
authorizations house report finds the
report by house democrats examining the
pandemic says trump officials sought
vaccine approvals to sway voters before
the 2020 election
isn't that a good thing
is that is that is that i don't
understand
they're they're starting to attack trump
because he got the vaccines out
that was like the good thing trump did i
can't believe trump did this to us
you know what um i'm changing my opinion
on him right now yeah here we go last
night we had james lindsey on and on the
after show we talked about the galleon
dialectic and i was like what's a
dialectic a dialectic is when you create
an opposition to what you're doing so
that you can create a conflict which
will get a new thing that you want yeah
so
this now they're creating a dialectic
now they're now what they're expecting
is information's going to come out oh i
got damaged by the vat all vaccines hurt
me oh vaccine now they're trying to be
like okay here's the com going to come
the thing to be a push against is trump
so that we're going to get our outcome
maybe maybe i don't i don't know i do
know and james i was like how do you
stop that from how do you defeat the
dialectic he's like well you expose it
it's like a magic trick if you show
people how to do the magic trick before
you show them the trick but but but hold
on i don't know if i agree with that um
i know there's a lot of people that are
not fans of the vaccine trump got booed
himself
youtube recently removed the rule and i
don't know when but probably in the past
couple of weeks it used to be that
youtube said you could not make claims
say uh saying that uh how do i phrase
this you you could not issue claims that
the the vaccine did not prevent or play
a role in the prevention of of cover
like that's a very weird legal language
that's gone now
now you can't claim
that the vaccine
doesn't prevent
serious illness or death it's like it's
weirdly phrased but basically
you can now claim i guess on youtube the
vaccine does not stop the infection of
covet or something like that the rules
have changed here's the crazy thing
youtube's rules
used to say that you couldn't claim
masks cause brain damage
they removed that
really i mean that's weird like like
what like i don't think it does it's
weird but you're allowed to claim it and
it stops oxygen
that was actually one of the rules the
rule used to be that you couldn't claim
masks reduced your oxygen level now you
can they removed that rule against it
they also removed the rule they said you
could not claim masks cause lung cancer
they removed that rule wow that's weird
i'm sorry i just got to say i'm not a
doctor or anything but i'm pretty sure
masks don't cause lung i don't think so
yeah i mean i see a lot of people
wearing masculine in a car and i could
see a correlate of brain damage
with that
i see what you're saying but look look
you know here's what correlation is not
causation that's right here's what i
want to say about all of this
youtube clearly has no idea what they're
talking about and i don't think i think
everybody should be very careful about
talking to politicians and pundits about
their health care i think fauci yeah he
was a doctor 30 years ago he's a doctor
by by title now
i wouldn't take advice from tv doctors
like fauci from politicians
find a medical professional you trust
and i and i always bring this up because
people are like
oh but doctors are wrong or bad and it's
like bro joe rogan had a doctor
i had a doctor like they did not
you know take the route you assume the
every doctor will take for you but just
make sure you trust the person you're
talking about multiple doctors you don't
just go to the doctor because that's the
doctor you gotta like seek people out
look for intelligence listen to people
and listen to many many people if you
went to a doctor and you were like doc i
gotta i got a bum knee and he went well
time to amputate you'd be like no i'm
going to leave but but here's what i
want to get to you mentioned that the
the hegelian dialectic like maybe
they're now teeing it up for people to
make claims about vaccines causing
injuries and things like that not so
fast nate silva responded with liberal
elites pressured pfizer to delay vaccine
until after the 2020 oh interesting too
this is really weird okay i i like to
pride myself on you know why would
someone say a thing and then you know i
have a thought or an idea not always
right but i'm like
here's my here's what i think i have no
idea what they're doing nate silver
coming out
smearing liberal elites saying they
pressured fizer to delight the vaccine
until after the election like that's
really really bad for them democrats
came out and said trump was trying to
rush the vaccine before the election
i don't know where this is going i i
heard a theory i don't remember where i
heard this one so you guys are welcome
to correct me in the chat and then you
adam sorry i just gotta squeeze this in
there because i heard a theory that
they're starting to realize that things
are going to start coming out people are
going to start filing lawsuits maybe
against spizer i don't even know how
that works and they're trying to get
ahead of it but i'm addressing that this
is the opposite of that nate silver is
coming out and attacking liberal elites
for delaying the vaccine he's saying
it's their fault
but but it's an inversion it's the
democrats tried stopping the vaccine
they're bad guys
that's what that's
that's what i'm saying
i don't understand last night when we're
talking about it we're like obviously
there's a lot of stories and claims
about vaccine injuries here's my here's
my view on this
we had on the surgeon general from
florida
and even he you know i don't put words
in his mouth but the idea seems to be
look man
if you give 200 million people four
shots like there's a propensity for
injury these things do happen and we
need to be careful that we're not
looking at a scale issue
as opposed to a frequency issue is it an
issue that you know x causes y amount of
injuries or is it
x you know causes like
is an issue that have a million people
one percent seems like a lot as opposed
to one percent of 100 seems like very
very little that's why i'm just like i'm
not going to pretend to be an expert on
this one and i really want to avoid the
partisanship my whole point here is last
night
in the member section we were talking
about how
they're starting to turn on the vaccine
like this this is this is the narrative
now all of a sudden they're like it's a
bad thing trump got it out and i saw
that and and we talked about it like if
they start turning on it in the next
couple of years they're going to say
it's all trump's fault but then nate
silver comes out what is it this is this
is today yeah he tweeted and he's saying
liberal elites tried blocking the
vaccine
it's very simple when the narrative
starts changing all you have to do is
share that jeff love or gif of stephen
colbert dancing with the vaccines oh
yeah that's all you have to do no don't
you i remember but that's why i'm not
convinced it's changing i don't know why
the democrats issued this report if nate
silver is going to come out you know on
tv or something and then actually use
that against democrats that's gonna that
that's gonna help swing states vote
republican or swing districts this is
also assuming that liberal elites are
democrats they might not even be
american
well he's talking about democrats
because they issue this report where
they're going after trump but my point
is you're a swing district right these
are not die-hard trumpers we go down to
loudoun county for instance and there's
a lot of people who are like leaning
conservative but they don't like trump
they don't like maga and stuff like that
democrats are trying to bank on that and
get those voters if nate silver is
coming out now and saying this and using
their own report against them those
moderate right-wing individuals are
going to be they like the vaccine
they're going to be mad at democrats for
i mean this is this is a weapon for
republicans in swing districts to come
out and be like democrats delayed this
they made the pandemic worse that's
basically what nate silver is saying i
even think like so even though it's
retiring a lot of things related to this
i think the ship is thinking sinking
lydia's point was the point i was going
to make as i think a lot of things are
sinking and falling apart and someone's
going to be left holding the bag and at
this point i think people are like it
wasn't me though i was not on that ship
i didn't agree with that look at look at
this right here quote trump pushed for
the vaccine approvals too fast is the
worst possible critique of the trump
administration's coveted policy silver
founder of 538 uh tweeted he then said
that probably saved a lot of lives if
anything approval should have been
faster
in a subsequent tweet he wrote liberal
public health elites pushed pfizer to
change its original protocols that
govern its authorization of vaccines so
that the decision would be put off until
after election day two years ago
that is a brutal condemnation of the
democratic establishment that they would
let you die
to beat donald trump
nate silver is tweeting that out
does that surprise anyone though what
surprises me is that
the democrats came out with a report
claiming donald trump was rushing
unproved treatments and the vaccine as
if it was a negative
instantly having that weaponized against
them to show that democrats were willing
to let people die during a pandemic
because they hated trump that much
always this is i don't this is weird oh
we saw what happened with coleman new
york
oh man i won't dive too deep in that but
uh gretchen whitmer gretchen whitman do
something yeah yeah i mean
dr dr levine yeah dr levine yep always
has been like they don't care about you
and i think it's it's like going after
uh it's an abusive relationship right
it's the uh it's the i deserve to be hit
you know like that's how these people
are living they're broken they think
they deserve whatever it is they're
getting and you know it's going to get
better one day if i just keep coming
home and you know dinner will be better
next time mandatory basic training for
all americans at age 18. done
they go well like exercise
yeah we gotta fix their diet too yeah
make sure that you need help you guys
know what basic training is right
about military yeah like boot camp yeah
i was kidding though but what i mean
well i am afraid that's all i know
how many vaccines should i have probably
eight i'm actually double vaccinated i
think the currency is i think it's 14 or
something i think it's no i think it's
cute i think it's five for covent now
five five total
i could be wrong because it's two for
the initial and then they've got three
boosters now i think i know there were
two boosters and i think they came out a
couple weeks ago and asked for a third
one yeah i think the the new one is
because because the it's for omicron or
no no no it's the new variant is
something else g something else i
believe
it's actually called ligma oh no okay
you say like the leadership doesn't care
about you or me it's and i kind of
believe that because they don't know who
you are they and they're just looking at
spreadsheets of numbers i have 750 000
constituents
26 of 26 000 have cancer 17 170 000 rob
and they've got these numbers and
they're trying to like move puzzle
pieces around if i do a vaccine that
prevents 36 percent and i do it to this
percentage of the population they have
no and that's not how medicine functions
realistically that's why they're looking
at 3d printing medicine individually
tailored to the individual i think
that's the future of medical practice in
a lot of we we were talking about the
other day
how
it wasn't until like 1993 clinical
trials had to include females
separate yeah so it used to be that they
would take uh
men give them a drug see what happened
and then said there you go women by body
weight and then eventually people were
like hey you know like women have
different hormones and different body
structures and these drugs aren't
working the same way so we started to
discover that painkillers for instance
weren't working on women they would you
know the painkillers we would give to
men would work they'd give the same ones
to women and would complain and the
doctors would be like they're just whiny
women you know and in reality it's like
hey wait a minute it's not working
so then i think it was in 1993 they were
like we need to have separate separate
clinical trials for male and female and
that's kind of amazing and now it's
probably going to go away because of
weird yeah how do they know where it's a
female though exactly thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you